てかぁぁぁぁぁ･･･
ゴールデンウィークなんだよなー･･･
やべえなー
ゴールデンウィークなー
出かけたいんすけど･･･
家にいよっと
Twitter
ｶﾞﾝﾊﾞｯﾃｸﾀﾞｻｲｯ!!
こんにちは
お料理大好き･･･
タラコ・パス･･･
タツター･･･ゲボフ先生です･･･
よろしくお願いします
今日調理するのはこちら！
うまい棒たちでございます！
まああれだ！
/\
（何見てんだよお前）
そういうことだ！
早く消費したいんですよ！！
全然減らないんで
何かゴールデンウィーク中
僕にもし会ったりしたら
うまい棒あげるんで
是非、声をかけてください！
というわけで早速うまい棒を調理して行きましょう
なんかね、潰して食ったりするとなんか
本物になる説みたいなのが･･･
あります･･･！
僕の中で
というわけで今日はですね、ちょっとこの
ふざけんじゃねえっ！
ってくらいあるうまい棒を消費するために
うまい棒でちょっと色々料理を作ってみようと
思います
何かさっきね、メモとったんですよ
とりあえずもう計算して
何と何を混ぜれば本物になるかっていうのを
何か僕の頭の中で想像したんで
それを実際に今回やっていこうと思います
これうまくいったら･･･
食費が
うきますよっ！
奥さん♡
というわけでやっていきましょう！
いたっ
用意するのは
コーンポタージュ３つと
多分お湯でいけるんちゃいますか？
お湯を温めます
茶碗を準備します！
とりあえず、うまい棒もう粉々にして
じょろろろろろ
で、もう、これだって
見るからにコンポタやん？
これもう別にさー
やる前からちょっと分かってね？ってとこあるよね
オッケーもう、もう、もういいんじゃない
もういいんじゃない
はい、というわけで早速お湯を入れていきましょう
もうこれで完成する説がある気がするんですけど
うまい棒「ｱﾁﾞｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｯ!!!!!」
うまい棒「ﾔﾒﾛｵｵｵｵｵｵｵ!!!!!」
うまい棒「ｷﾞｬｱｱｱｱｱｱｱ!!!!!」
うまい棒「ｼﾇｳｳｳｳｳｳ!!!!!」
うん･･･
うううん･･･ｗ
でもパッと見コンポタじゃねこれ？
いやもう本人といっても過言ではないでしょう
ちょっと混ぜます
\ﾄﾞﾝｶﾞﾗｶﾞｯｼｬｱｱｱﾝ!!/
あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"っ！！
はい、というわけで完成しました
でも見た感じ結構
いい線いってるのではないかなと思っておりますが･･･
いただきます！
※こうしてうまい棒はコンポタとして
一生を終えるのであった･･･
まずい、なんでだなんでだ？
あっ！あっ！
分かった、多分コンポタが少ないんだ！
コーンポタージュ１本であの甘さだから
もちろん水で薄めると甘くなくなるのは
当たり前だった
もっとコーンポタージュ入れてきます！
うまい棒「ｱﾁﾞｲｲｲｼﾇｳｳｳｳｯ!!!!!」
ああっ！
うまい棒「さすがにぬるくなってきたな」
うまい棒「いややっぱｱﾁﾞｲｲｲｲｯ!!!!!」
あっ！あっ！
おいお前ホントに家族･･･
だけは大事にしろよお？
ああっし！
出来ました！
コーンポタージュ　✖
粉々のうまい棒とお湯　〇
配分ミスったコーンポタージュみたいになってる･･･
混ぜたら何かそれっぽくなってきましたよこれ
いただきます
※こうしてうまい棒はコンポタ（モドキ）として
一生を終えるのであった･･･
※果たして彼はこんな最期で良かったのだろうか･･･
ああ～！
ああっ！
何か失敗したコーンポタージュの味ですね
（コーンポタージュ味、犬死に）
はい、次はたこ焼き味でございます！
これはシンプルに
たこ焼きの味がするんでなんか
水と混ぜてこう丸めちゃうと
たこ焼きになるんじゃねえかっていう
安易な発想でございます
やってみましょう！
まずは粉々にします
今は彼らはバラバラなんですけども
これをちょっと水分を利用して一塊にしてみます
はい！
出来やした！
はい、決して綺麗な丸とはいえないんですけども
一応一塊にはなってると思います
何かもうホントたこ焼きだなって一瞬でも錯覚したら
こいつの勝ち
じゃなかったらお前は
F○ck you（負けです）
凸（◎A◎）凸
もうこれはシンプルに
ご飯にかければ
ソースかつ丼ができるんじゃねえかっていう考えです
いやお肉禁止してるんで
こういうお菓子で紛らわして食うしかねえ
楽しみです！
頼むで！
※早送り
あ、まあまあまあまあまあ･･･
いやあ結局、あの･･･
ソースかつ丼の味がすればいいんで！
それだけを信じて僕はいただきます･･･
いただきます
（なぜか冷ましてから食う男）
/ｸﾞｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬｺﾞｯﾁｬｹﾞｯﾁｮﾎﾞｯｷｬﾒｯｷｬ\
あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"あ"っ！！！
惜しいいっ！
惜しい！
惜しいよお！
超、ソースかけたくなる味です
かつ丼って分かるじゃないですか
かつ丼の･･･なんか･･･
ソースかけてえっ！
いや、けど美味しい
ソースかけたらマジで美味しいと思います
マジで
うわこれ
これ完全に
（だったらソースをかければいいじゃんか）
もう、もちろん野菜サラダといえば
こう何か、丸めたらポテトサラダみたいに
なるんじゃねえかなっていう感じで
粉々に砕いた後に
お湯をかけて丸めます
うまい棒「痛い痛い！何すんだよお前ふざけんな！」
うまい棒「覚えてろよ･･･」
うまい棒「ｱﾁﾞｲｲｲｲ!!!!!」
（うまい棒、死"棒"確認）
できました！
すいません･･･
いただきます！
問題は味なのですよ･･･
失礼します！
/ｸﾞｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬｺﾞｯﾁｬｹﾞｯﾁｮﾎﾞｯｷｬﾒｯｷｬ\
ゲロです
※サラダ味とは「サラダ油をからめた塩味」という
意味であり、サラダの味がするわけではありません
チキンカレー味をご飯にかけると
カレーになって
くださいよおおおおお！！
あのね･･･！
お肉吸収してるとね
カレーも食べれないのよおおお！！
どこのカレー屋さんに行ってもさ
何か肉の破片がこう隠ぺいしてあって
カレーが食べれないんすよ僕
今年入って１回もカレー食ってないです
チキンカレーを今食べれたら嬉しいな♪
ぐらいの感じで頑張ってみようと思います
匂いだけはいっちょまえにカレーですね
うわ、ワンチャンあるんじゃねえかな
はい、見た目だけちょっとカレーっぽくなりました
結構期待してますこれ･･･
いただきます！
（またもや冷まそうとする男）
えっ！えっ！えっ！えっ！
ガハッ、エヘッ、エヘッヘ！
（うまい棒の粉が喉にひっかかって無事死亡）
もうこれも普通に
潰してご飯にかけたら
納豆かけご飯になるんじゃね？
ってな
俺の読みが正しければ
これをご飯にかけるだけでもう多分
納豆ご飯になると思います
えええああああっ！！
納豆です･･･
いい臭いですね･･･
かけていきまあす！
あっ･･･いい臭いですね･･･！
すげーすげー、納豆ご飯の臭いになっちゃった！
僕、納豆臭いは嫌いなんですけど
味は好きなんで
さあ、臭いに伴い
味までもが納豆ご飯になっていると嬉しい！
いただきます！
/ｸﾞｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬｺﾞｯﾁｬｹﾞｯﾁｮﾎﾞｯｷｬﾒｯｷｬ\
おっ！
おっ！おっ！
おっ！！おっ！！
おっ！！！おっ！！！
おっ！！！ああっ！！！
すごおおい！！
すごい！！！
すごい！！
/ｸﾞｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬｺﾞｯﾁｬｹﾞｯﾁｮﾎﾞｯｷｬﾒｯｷｬ\
ほあっ！
はあっ！！
ほあああああああああああ！！！！
あああぁぁぁ･･････
（もやし死亡　死因：納豆味すぎてショック死）
（次で最後となります）
皆、俺が何をしたいか分かるか？
この２つを混ぜることによって
てりやきチーズバーガーができる！
そもそもうまい棒を２本にしてればきっと！
いい感じの味になるんじゃないかなと
思います
作ります！
おうおうおうおうおうおうおう！
おお･･･これは期待できる･･･！
やべえ、なんか盛り塩みたいになってますが
蓋をします
うまい棒とパンだけで･･･
てりやきチーズバーガーを作ることは
可能だったのでしょうか！
いただきます！
ｹﾞﾎｯｹﾞﾎｯ!
ふんふんふんふん
ふんふんふん･･･
【ED】